three
interlocking claims but let's address
them um
first of all i don't know whether there
can be a
one theory of everything
because my reasoning is not tight enough
to have to make that proof one way or
the other
so at this point i have to remain
agnostic because i say from where i
stand it seems to be possible that there
can be a theory of everything and it
seems to be possible that they cannot
from a computationalist perspective
whenever you have a set of observations
that is fine finite you will be able to
construct a computational model that
explains how to make such betters
so in principle there can always be a
theory of everything that you observe
that's something that i cannot ex
they don't see a way around this so this
seems to be sound to me and i think that
can be formally proven
but uh
um and it seems to be almost trivial
that it's too proven so it's more
interesting the question is can you
narrow this down to a single one to one
theory of everything
right you will be always stuck with
infinitely many theories of everything
where most of these theories will be
super inelegant and uh redundant and
basically recordings of your
observations or
will there be one theory that is the
most elegant and explains everything
deeply and wraps it up
and of course if you think about the
space of all theories and think of them
as things that you can do in a language
and
in which you can define truths and if
you realize that the languages in which
you can define truths consistently these
are the computational languages it turns
out that all your models are going to be
automata and that you can sort the space
of automata by the length of the
definitions so it also seems that in
principle it should be possible to find
the shortest automaton between to every
pair of automata that you can construct
and connect with now the question is
what's your search procedure for all the
possible automata i do have a search
procedure that you can hope that
terminates
and this is uh not a question of whether
it's mathematically
possible but whether it's efficient so
you do is there an efficient strategy to
find a theory of everything that is the
shortest one
and so far we haven't found one
and it relates to uh what ai is doing in
machine learning when it tries to
identify what's going on in the domain
so while in principle we can always be
sure that we could be a brain in the vet
and everything is just a nefarious
conspiracy
that is playing out and because we
cannot exclude this we can never be sure
that our theory of everything is
is the best theory that could exist
of things so that's obviously the case
but if we take out this single thing and
make the assumption that reality is not
a conspiracy
i think then it look starts to look a
lot brighter
let's get to the notion of free will
i think that free will is tied into the
notion of agency
and the best
explanation of what an agent is that i
found so far is that an agent is a
control system
that is intrinsically combined with its
own set point generator a controlled
system is a notion from cybernetics it
means you have some system like a
thermostat
that is making a measurement using
sensors for instance the temperature in
the room and that has a factors by which
it can change the dynamics of the system
so the effector would be a switch that
turns the heating on and off and the
system that's being regulated is the
temperature in the room and the
temperature in the room is disturbed by
the environment
and a simple thermostat will only act on
its present measurement and then
translate this present measurement using
a single parameter into whether it
should switch or not and depending on
choosing that parameter well you have a
more efficient regulation or not
but if you want to be more efficient you
need to model the environment and the
dynamics of the system
and maybe the dynamics of the sensory
system and the actuator itself
when you can do this it means that you
model the future of the regulation
based on past observations so if you
endow the controller with the ability to
make a model of the future and use this
control model to fine-tune the actions
of the controller
it means that this a controller now is
more than a thermostat it's not going to
just optimize the temperature in the
room the next frame but it's going to
optimize the integral of the temperature
over a long time span so it basically
takes a long expectation horizon the
fast further it goes the better probably
and then it tries to minimize all the
temperature deviations from the ideal
temperature from the set point over that
time span and this means that depending
on the fidelity and detail of the model
of its environment and its interaction
with the environment and itself
it's going to be better and better if it
assumes that there are trajectories in
the world that are the result of its own
decisions
right by turning the temperature on and
off at this particular point in time i'm
going to get this in this result
depending on the weather outside
depending on how often people
open and close the door to the room at
different times of the day depending on
the aging of my sensor or the
distance of my sensor
to the heating and depending on whether
the
window and on top of the sensor is
currently open or closed and so on i get
lots and more more ways to differentiate
the event flow in the universe and the
past that the universe can take and the
interactions uh that i can have with the
universe that determine whether somebody
will open the window and so on and so on
right so you
have all these
points where the controller is a very
differentiated model of reality where
it's going to prefer some events of
others and is going to
assign its own decisions to these
trajectories and this decision making
necessarily happens under conditions of
uncertainty
which means the controller
will never be completely sure which one
is going to the right decision the
controller will have to make educated
guesses bets on the future
and this even includes the models of
itself right the better the control
system understands itself and the
limitations of its modeling ability the
better its models are going to be so at
some point of complexity this thing is
going to understand its own modeling
procedure to improve it and to find gaps
in it and so on
and
this also means that when it starts to
do this it is going to discover that
there are agents in the world other
controllers that have set points
generators and model the future and make
decisions for instance people that might
open the window when you make the room
too hot and you lose energy because of
that right so maybe not overheat the
room when people are in the room uh
right this this means you have to model
agency at some point and you will also
discover yourself as an agent in the
world as a controller as a set point
generator and the ability to model the
future
and
you will discover this before you
understand how your own modeling of the
future works
right so you also have to make bets on
how you work before you understand
yourself
right so you will discover a self model
the self model is the agent
where the contents of your own model are
driving the behavior of that agent
and it's a very particular agent it's
one where your reasoning and your
modeling has an influence on what this
agent is going to do a direct coupling
it's a very specific model a very
specific agent that you discover there
and so in some sense free will i think
is a perspective on decision making
under uncertainty
starting from the point where you
discover your own self model
up to the point where you deconstruct it
again
and of course you will deconstruct it
again at some point you will be able to
fully understand how you are operating
and once you do this making your
decision becomes indistinguishable from
predicting your decision
and because of computational
irreducibility often you will not be
able to predict the position before you
make it right
but
as soon as you understand that there's
just the computational process going on
and you are understand the properties of
that process you will no longer
experience yourself as having free will
free will is a particular kind of model
that happens as a result of your own
self model being a simulacrum instead of
being a high fidelity simulation of how
you actually work
right and we are young beings we don't
get very old it's very difficult for us
to get to the point where we fully
understand how we work
except in certain circumstances right
when we observe our children very often
we get to the point as parents that we
fully understand what they will be doing
in a given situation we can fully
understand their own actions and
anticipate their decisions and the child
might experience that it has free will
and we experience that the child has
revealed up to the point where we
suddenly understand oh this is what's
going on
and at this point i can completely
control the child because he can out
model it
right and it's only to the point where
this system is going to introduce levels
that are again reaching my own level
that decisions become unpredictable but
if i am a few levels of modeling depth
above the other agent that might think
that it's free will the free will starts
to disappear from my own perspective and
also happens in my own mind there's many
things that i do but i thought as a
child i'm acting i was out of my own
free will and now i understand how
mechanical it is and i can deal with
myself
by controlling myself by outmodeling
myself successively and becoming one
more complex in this way
and and all that you should the um the
computational process the probabilities
in the transition rules you would view
those as objective probabilities then
yes so there is also this issue that i
don't actually exist in the way in which
i model myself i only exist to some
degree of approximation i'm not this big
tree that is strictly implemented in
physical reality and more like a bunch
of a shrubbery
and some of the shrubbery is tasked with
making a model of myself as a tree
and that model is going to be a course
approximation so the fact that i am
unable to follow up on my plans means
that i'm only approximately implemented
right the rubber hand illusion is a good
example of how we're continually
redefining who we are right where you
tap and drag on the hand at the same
time you're tapping and dragging on a
rubber hand and
if you do it just right with the person
they'll take this rubber hand and
incorporate it into their body image so
we're always learning who we are
but those probabilities in that learning
process you would take as objective
probabilities and not free will kinds of
probabilities
um what does it mean that the
probability is objective it only means
based on the models in which which i
have currently made and if i go
far beyond back i
cannot assign an objective probability
to the probabilities that i am observing
because they are contingent on the
assumption for instance i'm currently
not in a dream
or that my memories are correct or that
my data are correct or that my the
theories that event and to establish the
relationships between my measurements
and my data and so on are correct so uh
i do agree that at some point there are
a lot of assumptions go into this and
these assumptions
differ with you are usually mild
because i make so many observations that
at some point i can the
errors cancel each other out or there's
so many people that can verify my ideas
and shut them down and so my ideas don't
exist in isolation they are being shot
against every philosophy and physics
book that i can get my hands on and that
i understand right and every
conversation that i have
so uh that doesn't mean that
i will discover the truth in this way
but it means that i discover many many
of the possible errors that i can make
and at some point i realized that there
is a finite space of theories that
exists
and that we are discovering the same
things again and again so when we ask
ourselves what are integers for instance
or what are rational numbers
there are many ways of making theories
about what integers are for instance we
can say that there are the cardinalities
of sets
or so basically you count members of a
set and this is an integer and all the
numbers of members of sets that you can
have are integers
or you can say that there are a
subsequent labeling scheme that's the
definition that i currently prefer
or you can use pianos axioms to
formalize them
and it turns out that they all describe
exactly the same thing
there are all different perspectives on
the same thing and once you understand
the larger space that arounds the
integers you also understand why there
are different perspectives because you
understand how these perspectives are
being constructed and you can show that
it's all the same thing and this so in
some sense the integers are a fractal
and you can describe this fractal using
a generator function and you can also
describe it in many other ways
and it seems that mathematics or all the
languages that we can use that work are
usually a small relatively
intelligible set of fractals
and they are the boundary of what is
intelligible to the human mind
but not that far above it and probably
still inside of it
so i'm more optimistic than you are